cette question de 2 minutes le temps de
la démocratie du mardi s'adresse à
Clément bonne ministre des Transports
alors Monsieur hatal puisque vous êtes
présent je pousse un cri d'alerte parce
que depuis la réforme blancaire la
France ne s'est plus compté non non je
vous adresse à vous monsieur àal samedi
entre 9000 et 10000 manifestants dans le
Tarne Clément bonne en annonce 2400
Samed dit en marge de ses rassemblement
une cinquantaine de personnes masquées
s'en prennent à une entreprise action
heureusement circonscrite par les
forceses de l'ordre que l'on remercie
monsieur le ministre en annonceel des
milliers alors évidemment je pousse un
cri également d'interpellation madame
rotaillot le gouvernement tourne
délibérément le dos à la communauté
scientifique qui ne cesse d'alerter sur
les effets de l'inaction climatique et
se fait déloger dimanche à coup de gaz
lacrimau lors d'un débat déclaré en
préfecture dans un champ privé prêté par
un agriculteur or que vaut une
démocratie qui relativise les savoirs
scientifiques nous alertez hier dans une
tribune Guillaume Carbou pendant ce
temps l'État a choisi de confier la
concession autoroutière à la société
atosca détenu à 60 % par deux deux
sociétés capital risque de droit
luxembourgeois sommes-nous d'accord
monsieur le ministre sur ce pourcentage
de 60 %. pendant ce temps l'État a
consenti un contrat de 55 ans avec la
société Tosca sommes-nous d'accord
monsieur le ministre que ce contrat a
bien été signé pour 55 ans et
pourriez-vous nous dire pourquoi une si
longue durée pourriez-vous également
nous confirmer qu'alon des formules
mathématiques figurant dans le contrat
hormis les véhicules électriques dont on
ne sait ni comment ni par quel
technologie seront repérés le tarif
entre castre et verfeille pour 53 km ne
serait déjà plus de 6,80 € soit 6,77 €
arrondi au terme du contrat à 6,80 €
mais de 7,90 € auquel il faut rajouter à
ce jour 1,70 € pour arriver jusqu'à
Toulouse par là 68 soit allerretour 19
20 € soit 100 € par semaine 96
exactement madame la député la parole
est à monsieur Clément bon ministre
délégué chargé des
[Applaudissements]
transports madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés madame la
députée harigi tout à votre complottisme
et à votre humour noir je regrette que
vous n'ayez pas commencé par le
commencement madame harigi que vous
n'ayez pas commencé madame arigi par les
principes républicains les plus
élémentaires que vous n'ayez pas
commencé par condamner les violences
inacceptables qui ont eu lieu et ça
n'est pas une question d'arithmétique à
part celle et le chiffre est
malheureusement élevé des se gendarmes
qui ont été blessés par des violences
scandaleuses madame la députée hargy je
regrette que vous n'ayez pas commencé
par saluer l'action des agents de l'État
du préfet du Tarne des forces de police
sous l'autorité du MIN d'intérieur qu'il
faut respecter l'ordre républicain je
regrette madame que vous n'z pas eu un
mot pour les fonctions ire de l'État pas
un mot pour appeler le nécessaire
respect du droit de manifester dans le
cadre de la République et de l'ordre
nécessaire madame la députée hargi ce
n'est pas une question d'arithmétique
c'est une question de démocratie je
regrette que N pas eu un mot pour
condamneré et vous cautionnez de faites
ces violences parce que madameg quel que
soit le nombre exact quel que soit le
nombre exact il y a eu des centaines et
même des milliers d'individus
radicalisés qui ont incendié ou pas vrai
madame qui ont incendié de bâtiments qui
ont empêché les pompiers d'éteindre
l'incendie madame qui ont porté parce
que Madame Rousseau a porté très loin
l'indescence en défendant le port de
canif avec des couteaux avec des pioches
qui ont voulu être violent alors madame
vous avez le droit d'être contre un
projet nous en avons discuté longuement
vous avez le droit d'encourager et de
participer à des manifestations vous
n'avez pas le droit d'oublier le respect
des principes républicains les plus
élémentaires quant à la discussion elle
a toujours été ouverte vous avez passé
des heures à en discuter avec moi vous
le savez mais il faut d'abord respecter
les principes nécessaires de notre
démocratie et notre État de droit merci
Monsieur le Ministre la
parole madame
GI vous n je ne crois pas il vous reste
pas de temps de parole non vous n'avez
plus temps de parole non non
non il ne reste plus de temps de parole
à Madame arigi c'était le temps de
parole de Monsieur le Ministre la parole
est à Monsieur al
David